so i mean looking at the sheerly abysmal
turnout that comes from these democratic
primaries you know we realized like
780 000 people live in my district in
new york city
and the prior year only 18 000 people
voted in the primary so i'm thinking man
like let's go find 20 000 voters and win
this race
and it's like so outside the box and and
i you know i talked to quote-unquote
experts and consultants and they said no
no no you don't understand there's only
18 000 triple prime voters here these
are the only people who consistently
vote in these primaries you're not going
to get people who are predisposed to not
voting in a primary to vote and i'm like
yeah yeah these people don't vote
because you've never tried to get them
engaged and so we came at that race from
this fundamental idea that every single
person was worth campaigning to that
nobody was uh prohibitively expensive to
campaign to or you know or unimportant
and that's how we did that race it was
inspired it was exciting to your point
we motivated thousands and thousands of
new
non-traditional voters to vote in our
primary
[Music]
this week on forward new york
congressional candidate business school
professor small business owner operator
suraj patel joins us saraj welcome thank
you very much for having me andrew so
siraj wow have you had a journey and you
and i have known each other for years i
first met you in 2018 when you were
running for congress and you lost that
race to the incumbent very very narrowly
uh like what was that vote count in 2018
i think it was uh we you know we lost it
57 to 43 but it was a lot closer than
anyone ever gave us credit for
going into that race and then you came
back and ran again and the second time
it was like a razor thin margin that
actually could have gone the other way
if they'd included a bunch of votes that
for whatever reason weren't counted
totally it's fundamentally the reason
i'm in this race again which is that you
know we've got liberal democracy under
attack across the world frankly um and
even right here at home you've got the
old tools of gerrymandering voter
suppression things like that two years
ago we lost by 2 700 votes in the first
sort of election that was happening
during the coronavirus crisis and new
york was woefully unprepared to
manage a vote-by-mail election which is
what it largely turned into so 20
of the ballots that came in by mail were
never ever opened andrew in our race um
one in five people
never had their vote counted a lot of
those votes came from areas we do really
well in a lot of those were due to post
office failing to postmark ballots or
the design of the ballots you know
omitted sort of a the right spot for a
signature that you needed it was just it
was a mess it was a mess um and i'm an
attorney you know i've talked about
gerrymandering voter suppression my
whole career
and you know politics is the only game
where the players are the umpires they
get to determine
uh you know the time place and manner of
their reelections and i always say like
the one thing that these people seem to
be very effective at uh in the
incumbents is
perpetuating their incumbency you know
yeah so i want to retrace our steps a
little bit because you and i share
a fair amount in common uh i was uh
excited about barack obama when he
became president probably doesn't
surprise anybody and you were so excited
that you worked on his campaigns is that
right that's right i was in law school
in 2007 when i just looked at this
campaign i said here's another skinny
kid with a funny name you know running
for president affirms sort of the idea
that people like you and me have a place
in politics have a place in america
parents my parents moved here from india
in the 60s um
and and i was so into it and one of the
things that i fundamentally loved was
this idea that you can disagree without
being disagreeable that
you know that there wasn't this idea
that people in the country are
irredeemable we were campaigning to
everyone trying to conv you know
convince and persuade them to come in i
feel like that some of that's been lost
a bit in the last couple of cycles that
you know it's a very us versus them
world anyway so i love law school i
joined the obama campaign became an
advanced staffer um much to my
indian parents dismay of leaving school
for a second
but it was just one of the most
incredible experiences of my life yeah
obama won that 0-8 campaign
was extraordinarily uplifting
remember
i wasn't as involved as you were but you
must have seen all these rapturous
crowds uh people investing a lot of
their hopes and dreams um i remember
celebrating when obama won
in 08 and his opponents that time were
john mccain and sarah palin and so it
really did seem like there's a very
significant gulf particularly where
sarah palin was concerned so uh he wins
and then do you consider joining the
administration though i guess there must
have been a multitude of people who
worked on the campaign who were thinking
about it totally and i also you know
wanted to come back and finish law
school so uh i was back at nyu finished
law school in 2010 at which point
you know my family moved here like i
said in the late 60s my dad was an mta
engineer
we ran a little bodega um i remember you
know sort of working with my family
sweeping that bodega floor
growing up then we started a small
business uh lived in a motel that we
that we had purchased um as a family and
did the laundry and the housekeeping and
filling the vending machines and grew up
working our family business and 2010
rolled around and we had the financial
crisis hit
and really upended everything that we
had spent a lifetime building together
so faced a few foreclosures bankruptcies
and so i kind of got very much like so
many people in our generation and my
generation
completely rerouted
in this once in a lifetime sort of
great recession situation so i went to
you know help come out of the
foreclosures with my family and made
sure that um you know we finished our
projects that our employees
landed on their feet that we made sure
that uh every contractor everyone was
paid in full but it took a long time man
it took a long time to dig out of that
and i think
frankly we need people to be running for
office who've gone through that kind of
[ __ ] yeah i i love small business owner
operators i was one here in new york uh
and there's just something very
pragmatic and reasonable about that
background because you know you can't be
ideological about you know like
providing a service to people
uh the way you treat people you're just
trying to put people in position to
succeed um so you volunteered again on
the obama campaign in 2012 and when did
you think hey i might run myself
so actually i worked uh on the 2012
campaign full time again wow that's a
big deal yeah yeah i went back and did
that again and then i also worked for
the white house doing advanced work you
know traveling around uh for you know i
went to india uh on behalf of the white
house for a few months for a month it
wasn't until 2016. look i never frankly
you know imagined running for office in
new york city frankly first off um and
for congress but 2016 was the big pivot
point um i was you know helping out on
the hillary campaign i was a consultant
towards the end of it the morning after
trump won i was working at the javits
center event which was supposed to be
our victory party it ended up becoming
feeling like a funeral frankly a group
of us decided you know there were like
junior obama staffers decided let's have
a
let's get an organization together and
start getting people under one roof and
thinking about where do we go next from
here
so we started this organization called
the arena
to get
new people to run for office to enter
the political arena
and it was incredible remember if you
remember that moment how many people are
part of that so we had summits across
the country and thousands of people
showed up over over the course of the
few months that we ran them uh year we
were in them so nashville tennessee
three a month after the election in
december of 2020 2016 um we had a summit
here's what i thought was incredible
700 people showed up from around the
country on their own dime to to and you
know that is a lot sit under one roof
and talk about you know some healing and
where do we go forward what i thought
was most fascinating is i was taking the
intake forms is half those people had
never been involved in politics they
were from tech they were from digital
they were from marketing their creatives
and we said look man we've got lapped by
republicans in terms of how we
communicate to people in the digital
sphere and all that
and so we started helping new candidates
run for office uh you know people like
lauren underwood people like andy kim
people who normally the democratic party
you know maine you know would just look
over
and say oh andy kim you're in southern
new jersey
it's a white area we're going to find
some former county supervisor and run
him you know and andy kim is like we
said look let's envelop this guy
with
cutting edge you know support and
technology and sort of break through and
and start campaigning to all people not
just people we determine are predisposed
to voting
so we did that and and and i realized my
own home here in new york city has been
represented by a person who's been in
office now for 30 years so out of touch
and
you know frankly in my district which is
the eastern half of manhattan a little
bit of greenpoint williamsburg and a
little bit of northern uh or western
queens
leads in almost every facet of american
life media entertainment technology
research development uh medicine
and then congress had sort of a
backbencher for a long time
who isn't pushing forth
on on envelope ideas and
and things like that and so i said look
someone should someone should challenge
these people competition brings out the
best in all of us i fundamentally
believe it yeah it's very unusual to
challenge an incumbent and actually have
a shot uh you know that's highly unusual
i mean the re-election rate for
incumbents is something like 94
yeah um so that was a very brash move
uh and despite your being associated
with democratic politics generally uh it
seems like your cast is very much an
interloper outsider is that fair to say
yeah incredibly disingenuous sort of
branding of someone who has spent their
entire life working on democratic
campaigns and causes
i consider myself you know an obama
democrat a liberal democrat
this idea that like if you
have the temerity to challenge and
incumbent
um that you're not playing for the team
that's absurd i was thinking look we
can't possibly be telling people across
the country from our coastal you know
from new york and california that
hey ohio voter you're voting against
your self-interest like nobody wants to
hear that first off you sound like a
condescending uh jerk
secondly
you've got to walk the walk if your own
congress people haven't within you know
new york uh you know safe seats have
delivered anything
for decades
um and you have fundamental issues with
the way that they have campaign and who
they campaign to and who they're
accountable to you have an obligation to
also you know keep these people honest
and run against them and that's what i
did in 2016 6.8 of people
voted in the primary
and you're like you know if you wonder
why why our representatives are so sort
of like narrow and and you know the only
campaign in one small group
have you ever heard of data brokers well
they've heard of you they are the
middlemen that collect and sell the
digital footprints that you leave online
they make detailed profiles and then
they sell your browsing history and your
online searches even your location data
to any company that wants to target you
does this sound like a good time it
doesn't sound like a good time to me
and one way to protect yourself is to do
what i do and use express vpn it's one
of the easiest ways to get your own data
under your control when you're connected
to expressvpn your ip address is hidden
high-end corporations use this for their
people it encrypts 100 of network
traffic to keep your data safe so make
sure your online activity and data are
protected with the best vpn money can
buy visit expressvpn.com
yang right now
and get three extra months free through
my special link that's expr
yang
expressvpn.com yang to learn more
[Music]
one of the the reasons why
um i'm excited to talk to you is the
experience you've had running against
what i'm going to characterize as
something of a democratic machine
and people would look at you and again
being like well isn't he also a democrat
yeah yeah and like
the machine is is is a is it is
real it's real
just this week
fast forwarding to now
the art of drawing lines is
gerrymandering and most people think
about gerrymandering from a partisan
uh perspective yeah so a little bit of
background here
a new york court threw out the
redistricting lines that were drawn by
new york democrats and this judge was
appointed by democrats new york is
essentially a one-party
state
and so this really
was
kind of surprising to a lot of people
because it's like hey even this judge
thought that this process was
problematic where they they drew the
lines they didn't consult with anyone
they said hey here are the lines and so
as we're having this conversation no one
knows what the lines are going to be
uh like the judge said look
like you have to do it again
and so now they're taking another shot
at it um but that they're there's a
chance that the dates shift they're like
no no we have to get these primaries
done in june but um for someone like you
you're not even sure what your lines are
is that right that's correct so they
punted our election to august 23rd we do
so they did move it back yeah my
election now will be august 23rd instead
of june 29th so that's one thing which
i'm you know
it gives us more time to make our case
which is great um on the one hand on the
other hand i don't know what the lines
are going to be but you know i had a law
professor always said like call me
old-fashioned but i think voters should
choose their politicians and not the
other way around
drawing excising surgically
you know populations that you don't
think you can get to support you
isn't good for democracy
in november we learned that my opponent
represented maloney according to new
york times
you know angled the shed thousands of
young and latino voters out of her
district so when i ran two years ago
almost every precinct that i won
curiously was surgically excised
out of the district this year now that
map has been tossed we'll see what the
court-appointed master draws
but the map that they replaced it with
was one that you know you could you
didn't have to infer it didn't have to
it didn't take much to in for
what had happened but the times also
reported it so there's obviously source
behind it but
it took communities like the upper west
side and chelsea and west village and
ripped them into half
in order to protect the incumbent and
most people think about gerrymandering
from the standpoint of partisanship
party versus party yeah
the most invidious type of
gerrymandering for decades has been
incumbency protection that a bunch of
democrats and republicans get in a room
together and they say hey here's my
seven people i want to save the
republicans are like here's my five
people i want to save and we draw
districts that are like just in more and
more quote unquote safe it's the
people's house the house representative
is supposed to move with the moods
right now only 30 plus 30 or so out of
435 seats are like actually compelling
yeah it's 90 non-competitive it's insane
that's an incredibly bad thing for
democracy and we wonder why these people
then are out of touch and why they're in
many cases so terrified more of
primaries than they are of the general
election that they move to their
respective corners well clearly in in
this district uh it's going to be
non-competitive in the general to the
extent that there's any uncertainty it's
in the primary but what makes you so
interesting is that
again incumbents have a 94 success rate
it's very very hard to successfully
primary and incumbent and the fact that
you have come this close to to
beating
uh an incumbent is really really like
somewhat singular and the fact that
you're back for a third time
third time's a charm run i commend you
for because as someone who's been a
candidate a couple times i mean it takes
a lot out of you you know especially in
your case where you come this close to
winning and then you you fall short you
know like it you must have very very
high levels of stamina resilience etc
etc so hats off to you on that siraj
yeah thank you to your point by the way
i think i i look i come
from the come at this from the
standpoint of you're right i've been in
hospitality i've been in business you
have to work with people you disagree
with you don't have the luxury of sort
of coming retreating to your corner
i am more convicted in my race now than
ever before that looking at what's
happening in the country looking at you
know our failure as as uh you know to
both to communicate what we've
accomplished but also deliver on so many
promises
we really need some massive generational
change in politics it's less ideological
and more about
new perspective fresh ideas championing
innovation championing you know
private sector growth and development a
lot of stuff that
seems to have been like left behind
um
in terms of governance you know and
uh if you know if you think about it
we're gonna have a pretty
you know all signs point to a difficult
midterm year for the course
and
every time there's a wipeout 1994 2010
every time there's a wipeout it's the
people that are like
in these battleground seats like the
andy kim's or the you know lauren
underwood's of the world
who will be 30 to 40 years old that are
you know in the office they're going to
get wiped out
the people who survive are the carolyn
maloneys of the world who have been in
office for 30 years in safe seats and
you've got this increasingly
you know a strange divide
in our governance where you've got
people who think you know oh um
everything's fine i'll just wait for the
next cycle to be in the majority again
i think we've got to rebuild from the
rubble that's going to come
something a lot less um
you know a lot more ideas driven and
effective and delivery driven and
innovative than what we see right now
you know yeah so a couple things i
endorsed a congressional candidate who
won um
in michigan
in 2020 and she said to me
uh that someone like her will never rise
to power in the party because she's in a
swing district and she won't just won't
be around long enough
because to get to seniority you'd have
to be there
10 12 20 years and she's like i'm not
gonna make it anywhere near that because
like you said when like the
um you know when the tide turns um you
know she's going to be among those that
gets wiped out and that really stuck
with me because who does then rise to
seniority people who are uh in very safe
seats on the coasts so you think nancy
pelosi you think folks in new york mean
you know again
uh one party but the second big theme
and one one of the reasons i think is
such an important conversation is that
democrats present themselves to some
extent as like the champions of
democracy it's like oh republicans are
sabotaging democracy
um and we the the democrats are the ones
that are going to to save it and then
you're like wait a minute
so like then why like really it's not
about democrats versus republicans it's
like incumbents versus
anyone who wants to come in and that
that's one of the things that i think
you just described when you talk about
the parties coming together including
and drawing these lines yeah look i mean
i think that there there is a
fundamental distinction in that um you
know republicans use voter suppression
tactics in a in a very sort of
race-based age-based way
across large swaths of the country i
agree you know and that's like not a
comparable and this is one of the things
that democrats will argue is like look
we're not the same as them and i agree
with that that's right
um but then when you press you're like
wait a minute like it's not like you
guys are necessarily pro-democracy when
it comes to the way the lines are drawn
the way the primaries are set up i mean
new york has very very closed primaries
that that lead to
uh
legislators
being chosen by what did you say 6.8 6.8
yeah i mean we we increased our you know
millennial turnout
uh
by 800 that first race and no one
expected us to do it it went from two
percent to about 16 so
you know and for people who are watching
this i remember working with
20-something-year-olds who were very
very inspired by sriracha's campaign
it's one reason why
uh
well you and i met
young people being like hey siraj patel
the future young dynamic energetic
diverse like all this stuff like where
they saw
uh the future in you and i thought like
wow like that would be really cool to
have this uh 30-something year old like
rep representing and shaking it up a
little bit challenging the incumbent uh
it's your point like this is the reason
that this is uh such an important race i
think that you know people should think
about care about from across the country
is that
you are talking about a safe democratic
district it is one i believe we have an
obligation to enter
uh you know to to use um
as a place to help change the
conversation to help introduce new and
innovative policy ideas that might
garner support from people in both
parties uh
it's an 80 78 college educated district
making it so far from the statistical
mean in the country that yeah so people
who know 35 of the country has a college
degree so 78 it's probably a few
standard deviations to the right of
everything you know it's the most
educated district in america and this is
where you have the ability to talk about
your kitchen table issues in many cases
are about the structure of our democracy
it is about climate change it is about
a moonshot in science and research and
development and innovation unleashing
the private sector uh to help you know
tackle climate change and pandemics
things like that those are the issues
that you know only a few districts in
america can you really make that your
pitch and argument
this is one that you can and we have an
obligation from districts like this then
to behave in such a manner to push the
envelope policy envelope forward which
is why i think it's so important
[Music]
so at this point you are a veteran
congressional candidate you've been
through it a couple times but like how
the heck does one gear up for a
congressional run so you say that you
hadn't considered running for office
trump wins in 16 it activates you
activated me too i decide to run for
president it sounds like you decide to
run for congress um so for those of
people who are listening who might have
in one corner of their mind thoughts
like hey maybe i should
throw my hat in the ring at one point
how the heck do you gear up to run uh
and then what does that process look
like well so in my instance um you know
it was a little unique in that i was
building an organization
to help get
uh non-non-traditional candidates let's
call them uh
running for office which are you know
younger people people of color
people with diverse backgrounds in
business and academia run for office
that's what we need
rather than people who have previously
run for office lower office or whatever
um so i was doing that and sort of
enveloping and helping other campaigns
launch and therefore it gave me some
idea as to what happened uh and so i
would encourage people to look for those
resources there are organizations like
emerge in the arena
and things out there for people to run
for office that can help you with those
first steps
but it really starts coming down to like
looking at the race that you're trying
to think about thinking about hey is
this person unsatisfactory and or
is there a path to victory
um the fundamental answer is yes there's
always a path to victory there are many
so what did you see as your your win
number when you were evaluating that
first time so i mean looking at the
sheerly abysmal turnout that comes from
these democratic primaries you know we
realized like
780 000 people live in my district in
new york city
and the prior year only 18 000 people
voted in the primary so i'm thinking man
like let's go find 20 000 voters and win
this race
and it's like so outside the box and and
i you know i talked to quote-unquote
experts and consultants and they said no
no no you don't understand there's only
18 000 triple prime voters here these
are the only people who consistently
vote in these primaries you're not going
to get people who are predisposed to not
voting in a primary to vote and i'm like
well you've created a vicious circle
haven't you if you think someone's
too expensive or unimportant to campaign
to you ignore them then they don't vote
and then you say see they don't vote
that's an unbelievable leaf a failed you
know customer inquiry first off it's
like i used to say politics is the only
business that blames its customers for
not buying a shitty product you know
it's like yeah yeah these people don't
vote because you've never tried to get
them
engaged and so we came at that race from
this fundamental idea that every single
person was worth campaigning to that
nobody was uh prohibitively expensive to
campaign to or you know or not
unimportant
and that's how we did that race and it
was inspired it was exciting to your
point we motivated thousands and
thousands of new non-traditional voters
to vote in our primary and what i didn't
do well in that first race is
certainly a lot of things and one was
particularly playing the game of
politics itself you know and campaigning
to some of the people who traditionally
vote
um media et cetera and you learn that
you learn that the hard way and i was
talking to my parents about sort of like
you know do i want to do the race and
they're like man when you know when we
built our first you know uh business
you know the next
the next couple years you think to
yourself man i overpaid for this or i
wish i did that the failure would be not
to apply those lessons
to the next one
you know and it was fundamentally um
really that's why i think our campaign
two years ago the second campaign was so
much more effective
um with the you know even despite
headwinds like covet happening in the
middle of it and fundraising dying
because of covid and all those kinds of
things
and then obviously the failure of
ballots and vote by mail and our
democracy but so you know coming back at
it this third time i feel like to your
point there are times a charm a lot of
people
you know don't run a third time but if
they did they'd win because you are just
climbing you know ro khan is an example
right this is a guy who ran three times
and uh really just kept doing it until
it hits well it certainly does take a
lot of stamina uh and resilience and
character to
run again
um so when you first started looking at
running and so that this is one of the
things that uh i you know like i i
know about the process that most people
at least imagine so the rule of thumb is
that you need to be able to raise
several hundred thousand dollars to run
a credible congressional campaign this
was an expensive district so you're
probably looking at some higher number
than that i think this is a single thing
that scares a lot of people off from
running for congress it's like who the
heck can raise a few hundred thousand
dollars from their personal network it's
very hard uh what's the the maximum
contribution and an individual can make
it's probably like 2800 sorry now it's 2
900 this year yeah yeah it's 2900 so if
you're the average person listening to
this thinking i'm gonna run for congress
you're thinking man how am i going to
get a few hundred thousand dollars like
you know i don't know 100 people are
going to give me 2900. if you know 100
people that can give you 2900 chances
are you're probably already in politics
it's so true that like these races cost
way too much um you know in our case you
know we don't to your point have a
competitive general election so it is
just the primary that help that's
helpful in in some cases you have to
raise money to win a primary then also
raise money to win the general and there
is an incredibly in you know insane
amount of money in politics and frankly
outside of politics that influences
these races so you also have that to
contend with super pacs you know i i
have uh you know the the good fortune
frankly of a really strong support
system of
alumni from university from law school
and stuff that i could tap you know into
a little bit but also this fundamental
issue of
representation there has never been
a south asian
representative east of the mississippi
river
in think about how many states there are
in new york new jersey connecticut which
has some of the highest concentration of
south asian americans and frankly asian
americans in the country
um
in new york at the time there was not a
single city councilman state senator
assembly person or a single of 500
statewide elected offices in new york a
single south asian person in office
currently now since then there's a city
councilman and an assemblywoman that's
it so you had a lot of thirst from this
ethnic community i hadn't really thought
about
how few south asian representatives are
until you said that in part because i i
know row
yeah you know that you know about right
yeah so when i i ran for
president my team around me was
predominantly non-asian
um and so they would look to me and be
like hey like are asians gonna get
behind this campaign
and then what i said to my team was
asians will get behind this campaign
after other people get behind this
campaign
like you just may not be first
i don't know if you had a similar
experience or did they pile in early on
you know similar experience from the
standpoint of definitely had some early
support but then we had to show
momentum and growth uh for this to not
just be a lark you know and um
certainly i'm finding now
uh you know more and more support from
the standpoint of you came within 2 700
votes of unseating an incumbent in a
very
you know what was thought of from the
outside as an impossible sort of
kickstarter quest now i'm like see i
told you you know uh you know if we'd
done this um from the get-go and and had
the resources to truly compete i mean i
was still outspent um by maloney two and
a half to one
uh and still only lost by 2 700 votes if
i had anywhere near parity um this cycle
we would we would crush it and
um
and we you know we plan to plan to just
continue growing right now
so you and this is one of the the
experiences i wanted to download from
you so you run for congress again you're
this charismatic 34 year old
south asian son of immigrants etc and so
you might have thought that there would
be a certain group of people that would
be excited about you i mean young people
were excited about you i know like a lot
of people who are excited about you
still but it did not seem like the press
was excited about you and this is
something that you know i went through
my version of this and then you're a
little bit like what's going on there's
like this caricature that gets painted
this is one of the challenges just being
asian-american in america
there is no home team yet for you the
press um in new york frankly is
it's an insular place to be running for
office and that that class is is that
a very difficult part of this i mean
let's let's start with the caricature of
just this like young uh you know random
person like one you know i'm 38 years
old now
in almost any industry in america that
would put me in the sort of middle man
middle age level
so
you should think about you know in the
1950s even the congress people on
average were in their late 30s 40s and
early 50s at latest that it was a young
person's game that it is actually you
know one of the first things you run for
and then as you get to senate or
whatever it gets older and older
the shift has happened in the last 50
years to where we're so drilled and
accustomed to thinking congressman
70. you know and this isn't about age
when i say generational change it's
about time in washington it's about
being in touch with the economy like
when i said liberal democracies under
attack with misinformation with cyber
warfare with platforms that govern sort
of with algorithms are public sphere and
people look at them even if you and i
know twitter is not real life and it's
not reporters seem to continue to
believe twitter in real life
and um
if you're going to be running you know
the country and saying we've got to
protect liberal democracy from these
attacks you've got to at least
understand those platforms you've got to
have been around in the economy and in
the private sector and places like that
at some point in your life well i think
this is one reason why you and i bonded
is that so i ran for president when i
was approximately
let's say 43 years old 44 years old um
and so i thought to myself it's like hey
you know this will be interesting i'll
be like the young
ethnic
upstart candidate and i thought that
there would be like a certain appeal to
that which there was to humans
a lot of other people
and also i'd be the first
asian-american man to run for president
in the modern era
so i thought okay there would be like
some people who are excited about that i
thought in the media
but it turns out that the media like
completely not excited
about it and one of the jokes that they
told is like i was the last non-white
presidential candidate on the debate
stage in
la
and then i was joking with my team i was
like well we're about to find out if
asians are white
[Laughter]
and and you did yeah i was like we're
not but um but but there there was still
like this uh complete muteness
about the fact that it's like uh you
know yang's like last candidate of of
color and like what does this mean
and there there is this uh conversation
particularly an online conversation that
takes a young
asian male candidate and completely like
expunges any
sort of groundbreakingness
like about that it's like like that's
not the groundbreakingness we need like
like that's not the new energy we need
we need some other form of new energy i
don't know if that seems familiar to you
it really does i mean look like my
family like
you know my first memory honest to god
is
we were a
uh 13 person three four generations of
family living in a one bedroom place
above this bodega we ran we slept in our
line my great-grandmother my grandmother
my grandfather mom dad aunt uncle me and
vero my brother my cousins
and and we would wake up at like five in
the morning on sundays to get the new
york times or another channel but the
newspaper
which back then if you got it if you run
in bodega you'd get it in separate
sections um like the front page the
business page and all that if you sorted
it yourself you could make an extra dime
uh you could make an extra dime selling
it and and we did that you know as kids
and as a family together
it's like
i know how this works
dime by dime you build a business you
build life you build something in this
country and you try to belong
and we should be celebrating those
things we should be celebrating people
success when they do or in families and
we shouldn't be denigrating it uh
frankly this is the hope we should have
for everybody
and i think that's what i mean by um you
know we need a new generation of leaders
that are pro-growth
you know pro-science pro-democracy um
full stop
and there's somehow been
a takeover of this idea that that
if you've had some semblance of success
in the the private sector that we should
we should consider demonizing you
in some manner and
i am damn proud of what my family has
built you know and to allow sacrifice
leave a country american dream really
yeah and leave a country
and move the hemisphere in half away to
like the place where you don't even
speak the language and sacrifice
everything
um send your kids to you know
university and all those things we
should be happy about that and we should
make sure that it's more accessible to
more people rather than saying
this isn't the kind of change we want
that's insane to me you know this is the
change we want this is the change
so how many new voters did you get in
that first race because whenever anyone
makes a plan around getting new voters
uh
like any consultant just runs the other
direction it's like that will never work
and that's what every consultant told us
which is why we said fine we'd do it
without consultants and do it the right
way and we we even made a little
customer messaging a customer guide like
bible which was like you know every
interaction we have shouldn't be like
sos911 this is north korea is it the end
of the world yes in the world please
rush me yeah rush me five dollars and 50
cents you know like our emails were
newsletters they provided information we
drew we wrote 170 pages of original
policy novel ideas to make government
work for people again you know it's one
thing to just be like
uh you know campaigning on on things
like you know medicare for all
which if it didn't get a vote you know
and i'm supportive of universal
healthcare and medicare for all but like
if you're not gonna you know if you
didn't get a single vote in this
congress when we had the house the
senate and the presidency then you're
being disingenuous if you're campaigning
on it um knowing full well that that the
delivery of it is probably long away so
then we're like well let's increase
price transparency in healthcare let's
make it so that the market starts to
work to bring costs down so more people
can afford healthcare you can do those
two things at the same time so we'd
write policy like that to sort of
innovate in government um and i think
that attracted a lot of people that
otherwise would be like yeah i'm just
tuning out the noise that's very
practical and real i appreciate it i
wrote a piece a few
weeks ago about the fact that uh
california state legislature failed to
bring medicare for all to a vote even
though they had like a super majority of
democrats i think it's literally 75
democrats and the governor ran on it and
then they didn't pass and i was like
look guys like if they can't pass it
under those circumstances
yeah yeah i mean there's this
interesting thing about
switching gears back to gerrymandering
for a second because i think so much of
what we're talking about the
counter-majoritarian impulses of our
government are because you know the
government isn't really representative
the elected government is not super
representative of of the actual populace
um it's it's very you know depolarized
and a very narrow set of folks who
really and it's gotten
overrun by various corporate interests i
mean that's what's happened in
california is that even though you have
a lot of folks who ran on medicare for
all you have very powerful lobbying
interests that are like look guys like
let's not totally vote on this and then
that one out because and that is one of
the dangers of having a one-party system
where they control everything
is that uh you know that they're
hand-in-hand with
with folks who just want to keep things
the same so if you expect that system to
deliver uh significant change you're
going to get more and more
frustrated and
yeah i mean look at look at new york
city if we paid 1.6 billion dollars a
kilometer to build the second avenue
subway line which was like 97 years late
that's that's six times the next closest
cost in the world paris uh and paris has
stronger labor and environmental rights
than new york does so
with a fundamental question of
accountability of where your tax dollars
are going if we're going to be good
stewards of them
if there's no strong
opposition of any kind ever then those
sort of things start to suffer you know
and competition again brings out the
best in us and if we don't really have
uh competition from the other party
which is fine um then we should have
competition from within this party
within the context of new york for
example uh by challenging incumbents and
questioning where the money is going and
what's happening
um i always joke like you know i think
at some level i think 51 is like the
sort of the highest tax bracket that a
new yorker could be in and pay which is
like sweden level but you're not seeing
sweden level services out there you walk
around
so like and that's not i'm not saying
that you know new yorkers are liberal i
am where everyone's happy to pay
their fair share and more but you have
to also be good stewards of people's
money you and i think you are uh you're
you're similar to me on this
where a lot of the
political conversations have uh revolved
around um how much money you're gonna
put to this how much money you're gonna
put into that and the real conversation
we have to have is are the resources
that are being dedicated to it actually
delivering in a way that people are like
okay like that that's money well spent
and and that's completely missing from
the convo like no one is saying like
this money went in
uh and then we we think that there were
like uh all of these great
um like accountability steps and like
you know people feel like it like it it
delivered uh above the weight class of
what was spent or any of that instead
it's just like you have these like
increasingly incoherent like we spent
this much on this and like oh spend more
spend less and it's like look a lot of
the the systems that we're struggling
with and i use schools as an example
it's like we're planning a lot of money
into some of these institutions
and they're not delivering and then
you're like oh you know what they need
it's like more money and it's like well
i'm not sure if putting more money in
actually is like the key variable here
it's like maybe in some cases but in
other cases it's like the money's going
in and you're just not getting what you
want out of it
and so that the goal i think for this
next generation of government ought to
be
us trying to see to it that what
government does is actually delivering
at a higher level yeah like
evidence-based policy-making it's
evidence-based sexy but it is like the
you know it's the gold standard across
the world now and
outcomes based you know monitoring like
these are all things that you know you
you should be thinking about when we're
talking about what these are i mean new
york has is the highest level of
homelessness since the great depression
and
you know you can't open the newspaper on
a every other day without seeing that
some
you know
you know some semblance of corruption
has occurred with a provider a shelter
that never actually provided services
that like you know if you're not fixing
that problem you can pour shovel money
into it we need both that's the answer
you know in some cases we just need both
but i i'm all for
massive investments in infrastructure
research and development and sp and and
sort of future focused things but like
i'd also love to be able to build
multiple subway lines with the same
amount of money than just just one yeah
because we've we're leaking you know
money for lack of accountability it's
funny siraj too another thing we have in
common i think is you become a de facto
uh political reformer because of your
interactions with the system
um and
when i talk to different groups of
voters so there's one segment
i'm going to call kind of apolitical and
i think a lot of asian americans fall in
this camp naturally because like uh i
don't know about your family but my
family was not talking about american
politics or
never were yeah
until i forced thrusted upon them pretty
apolitical yeah so apolitical and so the
the challenge then is try and make them
political which is typically then for
them to get behind individual candidates
who are democrats or or republicans
because that's what most candidates are
and then now with the forward party i'm
working on this political reform
movement because i'm like look this
duopoly
it's it's disenfranchising a lot of
people effectively you have 90 percent
of races that are non-competitive
because of
of uh gerrymandering and and other
things and so what's what's funny is
that i joke with folks too it's like
look like we're trying to do the hardest
thing because politics is sort of
exhausting
um you know a lot of very rational
people like look it makes me upset so
like let me not pay a lot of attention
to it so if you have the a political the
political and then there's like this
reform camp where it's like no it's not
enough for you just to be like you know
backing like candidates or candidate why
we actually need to fix the
structures the systems and that ends up
being a harder case to convey to people
very quickly i think the fastest way to
convey it to them is like this [ __ ] is
not working and when you say like this
[ __ ] you mean like this political system
this th
like
the entrenched interest the two-party
system whatever you want to call it so
i'm just sharing with you one of the
experiences that i've had now uh that
that i'm essentially like full-time
reformer um i don't know if that sounds
familiar to you at all either yeah look
i mean one thing that i think is curious
is when given the opportunity
via
referendum direct vote
uh across this country in republican and
democratic states and blue ones and red
ones
every single time voters have approved
independent redistricting commissions
over the state legislature being able to
do it so there are things in which you
know you can you can see that
wide slots of voters from all parties
want you know independent commissions so
that we're not looking at these like
safe you know out-of-touch districts 75
75 of americans want to overturn
citizens united right as an example
74 of americans want term limits for
members of congress uh you know i'm sure
75 of americans want independent uh like
redistricting oh totally um because uh
it's like having someone with a team
jersey on like be the referee it makes
no sense it's like like get me a referee
that's not from one of these teams
please
which by the way could very well be a
role for the forward party it's like
look just let's just make us your
secretaries of state because at least
then like we don't have a horse in the
fight and look this isn't this is a this
is about we should accept we should
welcome this we should welcome the
accountability
we as uh potential office holders office
holders democrats republicans should
welcome the accountability it'll make us
better it'll increase trust in our
institutions and our government again
um again we are truly under attack right
now
um in terms of liberal democracy in
terms of thought and and
you know accountability and speech
and and all those things and we've got
to find a way to to uh course correct
here
so that we don't see wide swaths of
americans completely detached from or
tired of the political process that's
how authoritarianism holds so your race
now you're back uh you don't know what
the lines are
[Laughter]
just another day in new york politics
you know
uh yeah uh you're gearing up for this
primary that's going to be the entire
race really because whoever wins that
primary wins yeah i don't even think
there's a republican candidate signed up
to be on the ballot yeah so you win it
yes
uh
um how can people help well look i mean
um
fundamentally
so there's three fundamental ways to
help us um and and we'd love to have it
which is um time money and networks
those are the three things i always say
you know we're knocking on doors we're
making phone calls throughout the summer
it's going to be an august 23rd primary
so
please hit us up on the website we're
looking for volunteers at all times
obviously we're a hundred percent human
um powered campaign we take no corporate
pac money i teach business ethics at nyu
i believe fundamentally that
you shouldn't take money from the very
same corporations you regulate so um you
know this is grassroots-built thing
anyone who can contribute please do on a
website and then networks this is new
york city but also these are races of
national implications if you're looking
for candidates um that are pro-growth
pro-democracy pro-science i'm your guy
and uh i want to sort of turn the page
on the failed politics of now
so if you're looking for people with
experience outside they want to solve
actual problems uh who want to reach
across the aisle frankly to solve
problems that's what i'm into um so you
know we'd love to
to do events fundraisers whatever we can
anywhere in the country because that's
these are national races um uh with
those implications yeah i mean needing
to work across the aisle is going to
become all the more important uh in in
the days to come what's your website
siraj it's
www.surajpatel.nyc that's
s-u-r-a-j-p-a-t-e-l
dot nyc well i can say and people can
sense this i would love to see you in
congress man it would make me very happy
and proud that someone like you can
still rise up defeat and come in
represent us
in congress and do great work so go get
them yeah thank you so much andrew i
really appreciate it
you